you know when we called Walt Disney and
asked him to present the Music Awards
tonight
he said well we said Walt with all the
songs you've commissioned for your
pictures and what would Fantasia and all
you'd be the right man to do it
after all think how much you've done for
music and Hollywood and his warm reply
was I would have thought it was the
other way around
in any case Walt fought his way through
all the Oscars in his living room to our
stage tonight one of the great
theatrical inventors of modern times mr.
Walt Disney right here
those nominated for the best music score
of a dramatic or comedy picture are high
noon Kramer United Artists Demetri TM
Caen Ivanhoe MGM Nicholas Rasta rose-cut
miracle Fatima Warner's Max Steiner
the thief Pupkin the United Artists
Herschel Burt Gilbert
Viva Zapata 20th Century Fox
Alex North and the winner is Dimitri
Thompkins for hi know
thank you very much
those nominated for the best scoring of
a musical picture our hands Christian
Andersen Goldwyn RKO
Walter Schroth the jazz singer Warner's
Rea hind orphan Max Steiner the medium
trans film Rupert Italian Gino Carlo
Menotti singing in the rain MGM Lenny
hatin with a song in my heart 20th
Century Fox Alfred Newman the winner is
the winner is Alfred Newman for me my
heart
thank you very much
say walk before you go any further let
me let me explain something here you
know you've seen these I know I'd like
to clear up just one little point
perhaps you've wondered ladies and
gentlemen why if the results are so
secret the orchestra always manages to
play the appropriate piece of music the
very second the winner is announced well
it's very simple for each award our
musicians have five different sheets of
music fanned out in front of them
the moment the winners name is mentioned
they pull out the right sheet in that
split-second the conductor gives the
downbeat and away they go
sounds a little frantic well it is we'll
give you a chance to see it work on this
next award
Walter it's yours those nominated for
the best song are I am in love from
sunup paleface paramount music and
lyrics Jack Brooke because your mind
from the picture of the same name MGM
music Nicholas Brodsky lyric Sammy Cahn
hi dune don't forsake me my darlin High
Noon Cramer United Artists music by dr.
Evie dimitri p I'm Ken
Ned Washington Thumbelina from Hans
Christian Andersen golden RKO music and
lyrics Frank Loesser
sing a little song from parama music
Harry Warren lyrics Leo Robin
the winner is Dimitri Thompkins
thank you everyone of you very much
thank you I feel like a mother of two
wonderful twins